THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION THÀNH WILL NOW
COME TO ORDER. I THINK IT'S BEEN
30S. GOOD AFTERNOON, AND WELCOME
TO EVERYBODY. WE HAVE 22
MEASURES ON THE AGENDA. OH, AND
IN CASE YOU DIDN'T NOTICE, I AM
NOT DAVE. SENATOR DAVE CORTESE.
I'M SENATOR ROGER NIELLO, AND
I'M CHAIRING THE MEETING BECAUSE
HE IS PRESENTING A BILL
ELSEWHERE AND WE'LL BE BACK TO
RELIEVE ME OF THESE DUTIES
SHORTLY, I'M SURE. BUT A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS, SO EVERYBODY
KNOWS ON EACH BILL WE WILL ALLOW
FOR TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
FAVOR AND TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. EACH, ALLOWED TWO
MINUTES AND THEN, ANY OTHER
PEOPLE, EITHER FOR OR AGAINST,
CAN OFFER ME TWO TESTIMONY.
MEANING YOU IDENTIFY YOURSELF,
WHO YOU'RE REPRESENTING AND
WHETHER YOU ARE FOR OR AGAINST
THE BILL, WE HAVE CONSENT ITEMS,
BUT WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM YET,
SO WE WON'T GO, TO THAT, LET'S
SEE. ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR. WE
NEED EIGHT. I BELIEVE. RIGHT.
EIGHT, NINE. BUT WE'LL SPEAK AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE. YEAH, WE NEED
NINE. YEAH. OKAY YOU'LL LET ME
KNOW WHEN WE GET THERE. YES. I
NEED A LOT OF HELP, WE WILL
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE, SO. SO
THE FIRST BILL UP IS THE FIRST
BILL, ASSEMBLYMAN FRIEDMAN, WHO
IS HERE AND READY. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. I AM PRESENTING AB
2290. I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE TEN, COMMENT
NINE OF THE ANALYSIS, AND I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
EXCELLENT AND THOROUGH ANALYSIS.
TRAFFIC FATALITIES, PARTICULARLY
FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE ROAD
USERS, BEING CYCLISTS AND
PEDESTRIANS, IS UNFORTUNATELY
INCREASING ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
MANY STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES
HAVE ADOPTED VISION ZERO
POLICIES TO TRY TO COMBAT THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS, AND MORE
PEOPLE ARE SHIFTING NOW TOWARDS
USING BIKES TOWARDS WALKING TO
WORK FOR THEIR OWN HEALTH. FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS, WE HAVE
CERTAINLY MANY PEOPLE WHO CAN'T
DRIVE FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS,
AND SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE PROTECT THEM. WE NEED TO
HELP CITIES WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THEIR VISION
ZERO PROGRAMS BY HELPING THEM
CREATE BIKEWAYS MORE QUICKLY,
IT'S SORT OF THE EASIEST THING
IN MANY CASES TO MAKE. AND YET
WE MAKE THE PROCESS VERY LONG
AND DIFFICULT. AB 2290 ENSURES
THAT STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES
ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF ROAD
REPAVING PROJECTS TO BUILD
BIKEWAYS THAT ALREADY HAVE
COMMUNITY SUPPORT DEMONSTRATED
THROUGH THEIR PLANNING
DOCUMENTATION WHEN THEY'RE USING
STATE TRANSPORTATION FUNDS.
FIRST, THE BILL WOULD ESTABLISH
A QUICK BUILD PROJECT PROJECTS
PILOT PROGRAM. DON'T SAY THAT
FIVE TIMES FAST WITHIN THE
CALTRANS MAINTENANCE PROGRAM TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT ALL 12 CALTRANS
DISTRICTS CAN QUICKLY AND MORE
COST EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENT
BIKEWAYS AS PART OF ROUTINE
REPAVING PROJECTS. AND AGAIN,
THESE ARE FOR PROJECTS THAT ARE
ALREADY PLANNED AND APPROVED.
THESE PROJECTS ARE DEFINED IN
THE BILL AS AN INTERIM CAPITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT THAT
REQUIRES MINOR CONSTRUCTION
ACTIVITIES, BUT IS BUILT WITH
DURABLE, LOW TO MODERATE COST
MATERIALS AND LASTS FROM 1 TO 5
YEARS. IN EXAMPLES OF QUICK
BUILD PROJECT TYPES INCLUDE
STREET FURNITURE SIGNS, BARRIER
ELEMENTS LIKE RAISED LANE
SEPARATORS, AND SURFACE
TREATMENTS LIKE STREET BOND
PAVEMENT COATING. SECOND, THE
BILL REQUIRES, WHEN FEASIBLE, A
BICYCLE FACILITY IDENTIFIED FOR
A STREET IN A BICYCLE PLANT OR
AN ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PLAN BE
INCLUDED IN A PROJECT FUNDED BY
THE ROAD MAINTENANCE AND
REHABILITATION PROGRAM. FINALLY,
IT HOLDS THAT SHARED LANE
MARKINGS, OR SHARROWS, BE
LIMITED TO USE ON STREETS WITH
POSTED SPEED LIMITS OF 25 MILES
AN HOUR OR LESS TO PROJECTS THAT
WILL REDUCE THE DESIGN SPEED TO
25MPH. AND THAT'S ONLY FOR
PROJECTS FUNDED BY THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. IF A
CITY WANTS TO DO THAT THEMSELF,
THAT'S ON THEM. WE DON'T STOP
THEM. THESE BIKEWAYS THEN, DO
NOT PROVIDE A DEDICATED LANE FOR
BICYCLING. AND AS A RESULT, THE
SHARROWS, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE NICE
ENOUGH, BUT THEY DON'T ACTUALLY
PROVIDE THE KIND OF SAFETY WE'RE
LOOKING FOR FROM THIS PROGRAM.
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF OUR
SPONSOR, CAL BIKE IS JEANNIE
WALD WALLER, AB 2290 IMPROVES
THE SAFETY AND QUALITY OF
BIKEWAYS IN CALIFORNIA. MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN WE SPEND TAXPAYER
MONEY, WE'RE ACTUALLY GETTING
THE MOST BANG FOR THE BUCK. AND
I URGE AN AYE VOTE. GO AHEAD.
YOU HAVE A WITNESS IN FAVOR? YES
YES. HI. JEANNIE WALLER, ON
BEHALF OF CAL BIKE, WERE THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL. WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN FOR CHAMPIONING BETTER
AND QUICKER BIKEWAYS BY
AUTHORING THIS BILL, CALIFORNIA
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE
MADE GREAT STRIDES IN PLANNING
FOR BIKE AND PEDESTRIAN
FACILITIES SINCE THE COMPLETE
STREETS ACT OF 2008 AND CALTRANS
ADOPTION OF ITS FIRST COMPLETE
STREETS POLICY. EXCUSE ME. THESE
PLANS SHOW BIKE FACILITIES THAT
HAVE STRONG COMMUNITY SUPPORT
THROUGH ENGAGEMENT IN THE
PLANNING PROCESS. HOWEVER,
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE PROJECTS
HAS BEEN TO SLOW TRAFFIC
FATALITIES FOR PEOPLE. WALKING
AND BIKING CONTINUE TO RISE AT
AN ALARMING RATE. OVER 1300
PEOPLE DIED WALKING AND BIKING
ON CALIFORNIA ROADWAYS IN 2021,
ACCORDING TO CALTRANS. THAT'S
50% HIGHER THAN IN 2013. THE
HIGHEST RISKS ARE TO VULNERABLE
ROAD USERS, SUCH AS OLDER
ADULTS, THOSE THAT LACK ACCESS
TO VEHICLES, AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE AND EQUITY
THROUGH OUR TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS, WE NEED TO EXPEDITE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SAFE BIKEWAYS
ON OUR STREETS. AB 2290 ALIGNS
STATE INVESTMENTS IN BIKE
FACILITIES WITH CURRENT CALTRANS
STANDARDS AND BEST PRACTICE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. IT WILL ALSO
ADVANCE COST EFFECTIVE BIKEWAY
IMPLEMENTATION THROUGH ROUTINE
REPAVING PROJECTS ON BOTH STATE
AND LOCAL ROADWAYS. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB 2290. AND DO YOU
HAVE ANOTHER PRIMARY WITNESS? WE
DO NOT Ó EXCELLENTLY EFFICIENT.
I IS THERE A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION, SEEING NO ONE COME
FORWARD? DO WE HAVE OTHER,
PEOPLE HERE THAT ARE IN FAVOR OF
THIS, FOR THE METOO TESTIMONY?
GOOD AFTERNOON, MARK VUKOVICH,
ON BEHALF OF STREETS FOR ALL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. TANISHKA
KANAKALA, ON BEHALF OF THE
JUNIOR PHILANTHROPIST FOUNDATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
KEITH DUNN HERE TODAY FOR THE
SELF-HELP COUNTIES COALITION. I
WANT TO JUST THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR ALWAYS BEING A GOOD PARTNER
AND WORKING TO IMPLEMENT SAFE
POLICIES AND WE'RE HERE HELPING
TO MOVE SOME STRONG POLICIES
THROUGH TO PROTECT BICYCLISTS.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
INTERMODAL TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
AND GOOD RECREATION FOR FOLKS.
SO WE'RE ENCOURAGED BY THESE
EFFORTS TO ENHANCE THOSE TYPES
OF PRACTICES. SO THANK YOU. AND,
IS THERE ARE THERE, ATTENDEES
HERE AND OPPOSITION FOR ME TO
TESTIMONY, SEEING THEM COME
FORWARD, WE WILL, BRING IT BACK
TO THE, DÍAS, QUESTIONS. YOU MAY
WANT TO STATE THE QUESTIONS.
YES. THANK YOU. I JUST WANTED TO
COMMENT THAT I THINK THIS IS A
GREAT BILL. IT HAS ELEMENTS OF A
BILL THAT I ALSO HAVE RELATED TO
HOW ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION FUNDS
CAN BE USED, AND LIMITING THE
USE OF THEM FOR SHARROWS, WHICH
DOES NOT CREATE MODE SHIFT
BECAUSE PEOPLE DO NOT FEEL SAFE
FOR RIDING TOGETHER WITH CARS,
ESPECIALLY ON STREETS THAT HAVE
HIGH SPEEDS AND HIGH VOLUMES.
AND SO I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT PART OF THE BILL, BUT ALSO
THE QUICK BUILD ASPECTS WE NEED
TO LEAN INTO THAT MORE. I THINK
IT TAKES SO LONG FOR PROJECTS TO
GO THROUGH THE PROCESS.
PERMANENT PROJECTS, AND
SOMETIMES USING MORE TEMPORARY
MATERIALS CAN CAN GET THE
PROJECT UP FASTER, BUT ALSO
CREATE THE TYPE OF MOVEMENT ON
THE ROAD THAT HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS WHAT'S NEEDED. SO
HAVING TO WAIT FOR THE EXPENSIVE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND LONG
PERMITTING PROCESS TO REALLY
DOESN'T SERVE OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AS WELL. SO I, I
APPRECIATE THAT THERE'S AN IDEA,
YOUR IDEA TO HAVE ONE PROJECT IN
EACH CALTRANS DISTRICT TO
DISTRIBUTE THESE PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, BUT JUST
IN GENERAL, QUICK BUILD SHOULD
BE MORE PART OF OUR ARSENAL THAN
IT IS RIGHT NOW. SO THANK YOU
FOR THIS BILL. AND WITH THAT I
WILL MOVE IT. THANK YOU. OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS, BY
MEMBERS, SEEING NONE. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I WOULD REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. OKAY. SO
THE MOTION IS TO WE'LL JUST MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT. OH THAT'S RIGHT.
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM. I'M
SORRY. I'M NEW AT THIS. BEAR
WITH ME. OUR, NEXT BILL WAS THE
FIRST BILL, ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
FRIEDMAN. NO. OKAY, SO. SO WHICH
AUTHORS DO WE HAVE? BEG YOUR
PARDON? NUMBER FOUR. NUMBER
FOUR, BILL CðC, NUMBER FOUR IS
NUMBER FIVE. YOURS IS FIVE. NO,
IT IS NUMBER FOUR. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VÆ VALLAPUDUA. DID HER A
SECOND. SHE CALLED IT. WHICH ONE
IS THAT? THE FIRST SIX. OKAY
WELL, SHE DIDN'T PULL IT UNTIL
SHE JUST WALKED AWAY AND. YEAH,
SHE JUST SAID YEAH, THAT NEEDS
COOLING. THANK YOU. CHAIR,
REMEMBER, IF YOU ARE READY, YOU
MAY PROCEED. I AM, THANK YOU,
CHAIR MEMBERS. I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AB 1853 TODAY TO UPDATE
SAN JOAQUIN REGIONAL TRANSIT
DISTRICT TO ALIGN THE AGENCY
AUTHORITY WITH THE AUTHORITIES
OF THE SIMILAR SIZED AGENCIES.
THIS BILL WOULD ADVANCE TWO
CHANGES. FIRST, IT WOULD BRING
MORE EQUITY PAY SCALE TO THE SAN
JOAQUIN REGIONAL TRANSIT
DISTRICT. IN COMPARISON TO 24
OTHER REGIONAL TRANSIT DISTRICTS
IN CALIFORNIA. SAN JOAQUIN RTD
CURRENTLY RANKS AMONG THE BOTTOM
THREE DISTRICTS FOR
COMPENSATION, THAT IS, THAT IS
ON THE BOARD FOR. BOARD MEMBERS
MAY RECEIVE FOR ATTENDANCE AT
EACH BOARD MEETING AT THEIR
TOTAL MONTHLY COMPENSATION.
SPECIFICALLY, THIS BILL WOULD
INCREASE THE SUM OF EACH MEMBER
OF THE RTD BOARD MAY RECEIVE FOR
ATTENDANCE AT EACH BOARD AND
COMMITTEE MEETING FROM $50 TO
$100, AND INCREASE THE MONTHLY
CAP FOR THE SUM OF 100 TO 500.
SECOND, THE BILL WOULD PROVIDE
RTD WITH GREATER FLEXIBILITY TO
INVEST ITS RESERVES AND
INVESTMENTS OPTIONS THAT
MAXIMIZE THE RETURNS.
SPECIFICALLY, THIS BILL WOULD
AUTHORIZE RTD TO ALSO INVEST IN
ANY INVESTMENTS OR DEPOSITS THAT
THE CITY, COUNTY, OR LOCAL
PUBLIC AGENCY MAY PLACE ITS
RESERVE WELL, INCLUDING
APPROPRIATE LIMITS THAT APPLY TO
THESE JURISDICTIONS. WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IS ALEX
CLIFFORD, CEO OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
REGIONAL TRANSIT DISTRICT.
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, I'M ALEX CLIFFORD.
I'M THE CEO AT SAN JOAQUIN
REGIONAL TRANSIT DISTRICT. I'M
HERE TODAY TO RESPECTFULLY URGE
SUPPORT FOR AB 1853, AN RTD
SPONSORED BILL THAT WOULD UPDATE
RTD'S AUTHORIZING STATUTES TO
FURTHER IMPROVE RTD'S GOVERNANCE
AND FISCAL MANAGEMENT.
SPECIFICALLY WE, AS THE
COMMITTEE NOTE, NOTES, REFLECT,
THIS BILL WOULD ADJUST FOR
INFLATION. THE COMPENSATION
LEVEL THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE
RTD BOARD MAY RECEIVE FOR THEIR
ATTENDANCE AT BOARD MEETINGS AND
COMMITTEE MEETINGS, AND CLARIFY
THE INVESTMENTS OR DEPOSITS IN
WHICH RTD MAY INVEST ITS
RESERVES. THESE MINOR UPDATES TO
RTD ARE AUTHORIZING. STATUTES
WOULD BRING OUR BOARD
COMPENSATION LEVELS CLOSER TO
THE BOARD COMPENSATION LEVELS OF
OTHER SIMILARLY SIZED TRANSIT
AGENCIES, AND BETTER ENSURE THAT
RTD BOARD MEMBERS ARE FAIRLY
COMPENSATED FOR THEIR OFFICIAL
WORK ON BEHALF OF OUR AGENCY.
OUR BOARD COMPENSATION LEVELS
HAVE NOT BEEN ADJUSTED SINCE OUR
AUTHORIZING STATUTES WENT INTO
EFFECT IN 1994. THESE UPDATES
WOULD ALSO CLARIFY THAT RTD MAY
INVEST ITS RESERVES IN THE SAME
FISCALLY SOUND INVESTMENT
OPTIONS THAT MANY OTHER TRANSIT
AGENCIES AND MUNICIPALITIES
ACROSS THE STATE CURRENTLY
INVEST IN. AGAIN, I URGE AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY. THANK YOU,
SO YOU ARE THE ONLY JUST ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS. IS THERE A
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION,
SEEING NO ONE COME FORWARD? DO
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL, SUPPORTERS
OF THIS MEASURE ON, ME TWO
TESTIMONY? DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPONENTS ON ME? TWO TESTIMONY
SEEING NONE. NONE COMING
FORWARD. WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DÍAS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS,
SEEING NONE. LET'S SEE. I DON'T
THINK WE'VE REACHED A QUORUM YET
, SO WE WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
BILL AND TAKE THE VOTE UP WHEN
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE AN AUTHOR? NO, WE DO
NOT. WE DO NOT HAVE AN AUTHOR.
WELL, WE WILL BE IN DELAY MODE.
ANYBODY HEARD ANY GOOD JOKES
LATELY? TWO POLITICIANS WALK
INTO A BAR. GIVE ME ONE MORE.
THE QUORUM, WHICH IS WHAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW. YES. NO WE HAVE.
WE WERE THERE YET. WE NEED
EIGHT. OKAY YOU'RE HERE, BUT WE
HAVE EIGHT. TO ESTABLISH QUORUM,
PLEASE. SENATORS CORTESE. NILO
HERE. NILO HERE. ALAN ARCHULETA.
BECKER. HERE. BECKER. HERE.
BLAKE. SPEER HERE. BLAKE. SPEER
HERE. DALLI. DALLI. HERE. DODD
HERE. DODD. HERE. GONZALEZ.
LIMÓN. NEWMAN HERE. NEWMAN.
HERE. NGUYEN. HERE. WHEN? HERE.
PORTANTINO I'M HERE. PORTANTINO.
HERE. SATO. UMBERG WE HAVE A
QUORUM, SO, WE CAN, FIRST OF
ALL, TAKE UP, CONSENT ITEMS. WE
HAVE, 14 MEMBER, MEASURES ON
CONSENT. THEY ARE ITEM FIVE, AB
2807 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER VÆ
VALLAPUDUA. ITEM SIX, AB 2333 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO, ITEM
SEVEN AB 1901 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN. ITEM EIGHT AB 1937 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. ITEM TEN
AB 2259 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER. ITEM 11 AB 2289 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LO Ã. ITEM 12
AB 2325 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE.
ITEM 13 AB 2367 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE. ITEM 14 AB 2590 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES. ITEM 16
ON AB 2815 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. ITEM 17 AB 3885
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON ITEM
20 Ã COR 121 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER. ITEM 21 ACR 126 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOE PATTERSON
AND, ITEM 22, SCR 151 BY SENATOR
STERN. DO I HAVE A MOTION FOR
CONSENT? CALENDAR MOTION BY,
SENATOR ARCHULETA, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SENATORS CORTESE, NILO
I NILO I ALLEN I ALLEN I
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I BECKER I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER. BLAKE
SPEER I DALLY DALLY I DODD DODD
I GONZALEZ. LIMÓN NEWMAN. NGUYEN
I WHEN I PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I
SATO. BERG NEWMAN. I'M SORRY,
I'M SORRY. NG¯ÜI NEWMAN I ON TWO
AND 1010 ZERO ON TEN ZERO ON TEN
ZERO. WILL LEAVE THAT ON CALL
FOR OTHERS TO MAKE UP, NOW WE'LL
TAKE UP ITEM TWO, PREVIOUSLY
PRESENTED, ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
FRIEDMAN AB 2290, ACTUALLY,
SENATOR BLAKE SPEER HAD MOVED IT
BEFORE. OKAY SO, WE'LL CALL THE
ROLL ON THAT. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO, AB 2290. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED. AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS CORTEZ
NILO NÓ, NILO NÓ, ALLEN ARCHER,
ALLEN I ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I
BECKER, BLAKE. BECKER, I BLAKE.
SPEER, BLAKE. SPEER I DALLI.
DALLI NØ DODD DODD I GONZALEZ,
LIMÓN NEWMAN, NGUYEN NØ. WHEN.
NØ PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I. SATO
UMBERG. 6 TO 3 ON KHÓ, THAT IS,
6 TO 3 WILL REMAIN ON CALL. AND
NOW WE'LL TAKE UP, ITEM NUMBER
FOUR, AB 1853 ASSEMBLY MEMBER VÆ
VALLAPUDUA. I DON'T THINK WE HAD
A MOTION ON THAT BEFORE, MOTION
BY SENATOR DODD, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR, AB 1853. THE MOTION IS Dð
PASS. SENATORS CORTESE, NILO I
NILO I ALLEN. ALLEN I ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I BECKER. BECKER I
BLAKE. SPEER. SHAKESPEARE I
DALLY. DOLLY I DODD DODD I
GONZALEZ. LIMON NEWMAN. NEWMAN I
WHEN I WHEN I PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I SATO. UMBERG. TEN
ZERO TEN ZERO. WE'LL KEEP THAT
OPEN, NOW ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE, AB 1122, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAINS, APPEARS SHE IS READY.
SUCCESS. WOULD YOU? YOU MAY
PRESENT ANY WHERE YOU LIKE,
ACTUALLY. OH, THAT WOULD BE NICE
TO SIT DOWN. EXCUSE IT. ALL
RIGHT. PROCEED. AWESOME. THANK
YOU. CHAIRMAN NILO. THANK YOU,
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB
1122. FIRST, LET ME THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THE BILL, THERE ARE A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS WHO ARE WHO CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT OUR PORTS, OUR
MARINE ENVIRONMENT AND THE
SAFETY OF OUR MARITIME WORKFORCE
. THE BILL, IN PRINT TODAY,
REFLECTS THE COMMITTEE'S
ENGAGEMENT WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
, AND I APPRECIATE THE MANY
SUGGESTIONS AND IMPROVEMENTS WE
HAVE MADE TO THE BILL OVER THE
PAST FEW WEEKS. CALIFORNIA LEADS
THE NATION IN ENVIRONMENTAL
PROGRESS AND OUR PORTS ARE A
VITAL PART OF OUR ECONOMY. BUT
WE MUST ALWAYS ENSURE THAT OUR
PROGRESS DOES NOT COME AT THE
EXPENSE OF SAFETY OR THE
WELL-BEING OF OUR MARITIME
WORKFORCE. CARB HAS PROPOSED
PROPOSED AMBITIOUS NEW ENGINE
REQUIREMENTS ON COMMERCIAL
HARBOR CRAFT THAT WILL REDUCE
AIR POLLUTION BY REQUIRING
EXISTING VESSELS TO EITHER BE
REPLACED WITH NEWER MODELS OR
RETROFITTED WITH NEWER ENGINE
TECHNOLOGIES. SOME OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY HAS NOT BEEN INVENTED
YET, BUT IT WILL BE REQUIRED TO
MEET CARB'S NEW REGULATIONS. ONE
OF THE FUTURE PIECES OF
TECHNOLOGY THAT THE CARB
AMENDMENTS REQUIRE IS THE
DEPLOYMENT OF DIESEL PARTICULATE
FILTERS. WHILE THESE DEVICES
DPFS EXIST FOR TRUCKS, THERE ARE
CURRENTLY NO DPFS AVAILABLE OR
APPROVED FOR COMMERCIAL HARBOR
CRAFT BECAUSE OF THE
TEMPERATURES REQUIRED FOR THESE
FILTERS TO OPERATE CORRECTLY,
THEY POSE UNIQUE SAFETY CONCERNS
FOR VESSELS IN THE EVENT OF A
FIRE. A REDUCTION IN PROPULSION,
OR A REDUCED ABILITY TO MANEUVER
. UNLIKE TRUCKS, HARBOR CRAFTS
CANNOT SIMPLY PULL TO THE SIDE
OF THE ROAD, AND IN AN EVENT
THAT FORCES CREW TO ABANDON SHIP
, CAN HAVE DISASTROUS
CONSEQUENCES. AS A RESULT OF
THESE SAFETY CONCERNS, THE U.S.
COAST GUARD, THE MARITIME
INDUSTRY, AND UNIONS
REPRESENTING VESSEL WORKERS
REQUESTED THAT CARB INCLUDE IN
ITS REGULATIONS A BYPASS FEATURE
THAT WOULD ALLOW THE CAPTAIN TO
TURN THE DPF OFF IN AN EMERGENCY
. IF AN EMERGENCY WERE TO OCCUR,
THIS WOULD ALLOW A VESSEL TO
RESTORE FULL ENGINE POWER UNTIL
THE EMERGENCY ENDS. WITHOUT THE
SAFEGUARDS OF A BYPASS, A LOSS
OF POWER COULD LEAD TO
ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTERS. DAMAGE
TO PORT INFRASTRUCTURE, AND VERY
SERIOUSLY ENDANGER LIVES.
UNFORTUNATELY, DESPITE RECEIVING
BROAD RANGING PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF A BYPASS SYSTEM, CARB
HAS REJECTED THOSE REQUESTS AND
ADOPTED THE NEW REGULATIONS. I
INTRODUCED AB 1122 LAST YEAR
AFTER HEARING THAT THESE SAFETY
CONCERNS HAD BEEN IGNORED AND
THE BILL BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ENSURES THAT DPFS INCLUDE
A BYPASS SYSTEM. THE BILL ALSO
INCLUDES REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
THAT APPLY ANY TIME THE BYPASS
SYSTEM IS USED TO ENSURE WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT EMERGENCY
SITUATION CAUSED THE CAPTAIN TO
ACTIVATE THE BYPASS AND HOW LONG
THE BYPASS WAS IN USE, AND HOW
THE BYPASS HELPED MITIGATE THE
EMERGENCY. SO THERE IS AN OVER
ABUSE OF THIS SYSTEM. THE OTHER
PROVISION IN THE BILL IS
DESIGNED TO PROTECT THE INCOME
OF WORKERS BY ALIGNING DRY
DOCKING SCHEDULES. CURRENTLY THE
US COAST GUARD REQUIRES HARBOR
CRAFT OPERATING IN SALT WATER TO
BE PULLED OUT OF THE WATER AND
INSPECTED EVERY 30 MONTHS, AND
THESE SAME VESSELS WILL ALSO
REQUIRE A COAST GUARD INSPECTION
AFTER THEY ARE RETROFITTED WITH
NEW CARB COMPLIANT ENGINES.
WHILE VESSELS ARE IN DRY DOCK,
CREWS ARE NOT PAID, AND THE
UNIONS HAVE ESTIMATED THAT THEIR
MEMBERS COULD LOSE ABOUT 25 TO
30% OF THEIR INCOME FOR VESSELS
TO COMPLY WITH THE NEW CARB
RULES, AB 1122 ADDRESSES THIS
PROBLEM BY ALLOWING VESSELS TO
ALIGN THEIR COAST GUARD
INSPECTION WITH THE REQUIREMENT
TO INSTALL NEW ENGINES, ALLOWING
ALLOWING FOR. THIS ALIGNMENT
ADDRESSES THE IMPACT TO UNION
WAGES BY MINIMIZING A VESSEL'S
DRY DOCK PERIOD AND ALIGNING IT
WITH TIMES CREWS ALREADY EXPECT
TO BE ON LAND. I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK ALL OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS WHO HAVE
SUBMITTED A LETTER OF CONCERN ON
THIS BILL. THEY HAVE MY
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THEM TO ENSURE BAD ACTORS
CANNOT ABUSE THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL. AS I HAVE OUTLINED
BEFORE UP A LITTLE AGO, WE HAVE
DRAFTED AB 1122 WITH THE INTENT
TO BE NARROW AND TAILORED IN
ADDRESSING THE LEGITIMATE SAFETY
AND ECONOMIC CONCERNS RAISED BY
STAKEHOLDERS. I APPRECIATE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY'S
CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT, AND I AM
HAPPY TO REPORT THAT THIS BILL
HAS ZERO OPPOSITION. I ALSO
WANTED TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
ADDRESS THE QUESTION OF WHY IS
DOCTOR BAYNES FROM KERN COUNTY,
AUTHORING A BILL LIKE THIS? AND
I WILL TELL YOU THIS AS A PERSON
THAT WORKS FOR DISASTER
MANAGEMENT, I CURRENTLY WORK
WITH MSA AND CALUMET. THIS WAS
BROUGHT TO MY CONCERN BY THE US
COAST GUARD WHEN I WAS ACTIVELY
HELPING PROVIDE A DISASTER
MANAGEMENT PROTOCOL EVENT FOR A
MASS CASUALTY CRUISE SHIP EVENT
THAT WE PUT TOGETHER WITH MSA
AND CALUMET LAST YEAR, AND WE
DID IT AT THE BASE IN PETALUMA
LAST YEAR AT THIS TIME, AND THIS
WAS A CONCERN THAT WAS BEING
TALKED ABOUT AMONGST THE US
COAST GUARDS AT THAT TIME. SO IN
ADDITION TO BEING A LEGISLATOR,
I ALSO HAVE A DIVERSE BACKGROUND
IN DISASTER MANAGEMENT AND
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND PREVENTION
IS AT THE Kò OF WHAT I DO, WITH
ME IN SUPPORT, WE HAVE THE THREE
MARITIME UNIONS, INCLUDING THE
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATION OF
MASTERS, MASON PILOTS, THE
INLAND BOATMEN'S UNION, AND THE
MAYOR AND THE MARINE ENGINEERS
BENEFICIAL ASSOCIATION, AS WELL
AS THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND THE AMERICAN
WATERWAYS OPERATORS, AMONG
OTHERS. WITH ME TODAY, I HAVE
CLAUDIA CHIMINI, WHO IS THE
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT FOR
MEBA AND WE HAVE ALSO KYLE
BURLESON. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. PROCEED. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIRMAN,
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M CLAUDIA CHIMINI. I'M THE
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
MARINE ENGINEERS BENEFICIAL
ASSOCIATION. MEBA IS THE
NATION'S OLDEST MARITIME LABOR
UNION DATING TO 1875, AND WAS
FOUNDED BECAUSE OF SAFETY,
BECAUSE ENGINEERS WERE GETTING
MAIMED AND KILLED IN BOILER
EXPLOSIONS ON THE GREAT LAKES.
WE REPRESENT A LARGE AND DIVERSE
MIX OF ENGINEERS AND DECK
OFFICERS, EXPERIENCED AND
SKILLED IN ALL ASPECTS OF THE
MARITIME WORKFORCE. MBA'S NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY IS THAT OUR MEMBERS
ARE SAFE ON THE JOB AND GET HOME
TO THEIR FAMILIES SAFELY. THE
SECOND PRIORITY IS TO ENSURE
THAT OUR MEMBERS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK THIS MEASURE
ACCOMPLISHES BOTH AND THAT IS
WHY WE ARE CO-SPONSORING THIS
MEASURE WITH THE MASTER'S MATES
AND PILOTS IN THE INLAND
BOATMEN'S UNION. NONE OF OUR
UNIONS WILL CREW A VESSEL UNLESS
THE COMPANIES ENSURE THAT
EVERYTHING ON BOARD IS
CONDUCTED. ACCORDING TO THE
UNITED STATES COAST GUARD
STANDARDS AND INDEPENDENTLY
INSPECTED, IT IS ONLY THEN THAT
WE HAVE SOME PEACE OF MIND THAT
OUR MEMBERS WILL RETURN HOME
SAFE FROM ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS PROFESSIONS THERE IS.
CONSIDER THE DAMAGE THE
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS WREAKED THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS ON THE
STATE, AND THEN REALIZED THAT
OUR MEMBERS ARE WORKING 24 OVER
SEVEN THROUGH THESE CONDITIONS
ON A VESSEL. ENGINES ARE NOT
SIMPLY THE GAS PEDAL. ENGINES
ARE ALSO THE BRAKES. THEY'RE
ALSO THE STEERING. SIMPLY PUT,
ANYTHING THAT CAN GET IN THE WAY
OF PROPERLY AND FULLY
FUNCTIONING ENGINES CREATES A
SERIOUS SAFETY ISSUE THAT
ENDANGERS THE CREW,
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. WE NEED ONLY LOOK
TO LAST MONTH IN THE PORT OF
BALTIMORE TO UNDERSTAND HOW FAST
AND SIGNIFICANT A LOSS OF POWER
IS TO A VESSEL. THE FRANCIS
SCOTT KEY BRIDGE COLLAPSED,
CHEMICALS WERE RELEASED INTO THE
ENVIRONMENT AND MOST TRAGICALLY,
SIX LIVES WERE LOST. LESS THAN
TWO WEEKS LATER, IN NEW YORK, A
CRISIS WAS AVERTED BECAUSE THE
TUGS ASSISTING HAD IMMEDIATE
ACCESS TO FULL ENGINE POWER, AND
THEY NEEDED EVERY BIT OF THAT
POWER TO STOP THAT 1145 FOOT
QUINT FOR A FOOTBALL FIELD
LONGER THAN THE DOLLY. THE OTHER
PORTION OF THE SPILL ENSURES
THERE ARE NO UNNECESSARY
DISRUPTIONS TO MEMBERS BEING
ABLE TO WORK. OUR MEMBERS ONLY
EARN INCOME WHEN THE VESSEL IS
IN THE WATER. DRY DOCK
INSPECTIONS, RETROFITS, AND
UPGRADES CAN TAKE 3 TO 5 MONTHS
TO CONDUCT. VESSELS ARE REQUIRED
TO BE DRYDOCKED EVERY TWO AND A
HALF YEARS IF THEY WORK IN SALT
WATER. THE VESSELS ARE ALREADY
SCHEDULED FOR USCG INSPECTIONS
AND ENSURING THAT THEY DO NOT
HAVE TO BE PULLED OUT BETWEEN
THOSE INSPECTIONS MEANS OUR
MEMBERS DON'T LOSE THAT INCOME
TWICE. IF THIS IS NOT DONE, IT
WOULD MEAN THAT OUR MEMBERS
WOULD LOSE 25 TO 30% OF THEIR
INCOME, MR. CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS, THIS BILL IS ABOUT THE
SAFETY AND INCOME OF THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO WORK IN EXTREME
CONDITIONS TO KEEP OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OUR BEAUTIFUL
COASTS PROTECTED. AMOEBA MMP AND
IBU APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF
OUR MEMBERS. THANK YOU. AND OUR
CHAIR IS BACK. PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, COMMITTEE MEMBERS, MY
NAME IS KYLE BURLESON. I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF STATE ADVOCACY FOR
THE AMERICAN WATERWAYS
OPERATORS, WHICH IS THE ADVOCATE
RESOURCE AND UNITED VOICE FOR
THE TUGBOAT, TOWBOAT AND BARGE
INDUSTRY. TOWING AND TOWING
INDUSTRY APPRECIATES CHAIRMAN
CORTEZ FOR HEARING THIS BILL AND
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAINES FOR
CHAMPIONING CHAMPIONING
WORKPLACE SAFETY FOR MARINERS.
AS I SHARED WITH ASSEMBLYMAN, AS
I SHARED WITH ASSEMBLYMAN MIKE
GIBSON'S HEARING AT THE PORT OF
SAN FRANCISCO, NOVEMBER, THE
BARGE AND TOWING INDUSTRY IS THE
MOST SUSTAINABLE FORM OF TRADE
FOR TRANSPORTATION, WITH RAIL
PRODUCING 43% MORE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS THAN BARGE
TRANSPORTATION AND TRUCKS
PRODUCING OVER 800% MORE.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE VERY PROUD
OF ITS MARITIME IMPORTANCE,
RANKING THIRD ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IN WATERBORNE COMMERCE BY TON
239 MILLION TONS OF FREIGHT MOVE
BY VESSELS IN CALIFORNIA EACH
YEAR, CREATING MORE THAN $12
BILLION IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
OUR MEMBERS FOOTPRINT STRETCHES
FROM SAN DIEGO TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN THE INLAND PORT
SYSTEM IN BETWEEN. SO WITH THIS
BACKDROP, WE ASK YOU TO PASS AB
1122, IN THE NAME OF WORKPLACE
SAFETY WITH RECENT CHANGES TO
THE COMMERCIAL HARBOR CRAFT
RULE, OUR INDUSTRY HAS SPOKEN UP
ALONG THE WAY ALL ALONG THE WAY
THAT THERE IS AN ODD AND
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS PROVISION
THAT NEEDS CORRECTING.
UNFORTUNATELY, CARB HAS IGNORED
OUR PLEAS. WE'RE TURNING OUR
VOICE TO YOU AND WE ARE JOINED
BY THE THREE MOST PROMINENT
UNIONS THAT WORK WITHIN THE
TOWING INDUSTRY, INCLUDING THE
MASTERS, MATES AND PILOTS,
MARINE ENGINEERS BENEFICIAL
ASSOCIATION AND THE INLAND
BOATMEN'S UNION. IT ALSO BEARS
MENTIONING THAT THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION HAS PLEDGED ITS
SUPPORT TO THIS BILL. WE'RE
ASKING THAT BEFORE DIESEL
PARTICULATE FILTERS ARE REQUIRED
TO BE INSTALLED, THE STANDARD
SAFETY PROCESS IS FOLLOWED.
WHENEVER NEW EQUIPMENT IS
INSTALLED ON A VESSEL. A THIRD
PARTY AUDITOR VETS THE PRODUCT
TO ENSURE THAT IT IS SAFE AND
WILL NOT CATCH FIRE UNDER
DURESS. FOR WHATEVER REASON,
CARB IS BYPASSED. THESE SAFETY
EXPERTS, IF DPS SOUND FAMILIAR
TO YOU, IT'S BECAUSE OF THE
FIRES THEY HAVE STARTED ON
SCHOOL BUSSES AND SEMI TRUCKS.
THESE DPFS NEED CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE OF THEIR
INFAMOUS HISTORY AND THE SIZE
AND STABILITY CONCERNS THEY
CREATE ON TOWING VESSELS. IF YOU
CAN IMAGINE TRYING TO STICK TWO
VW BUGS ON A TUGBOAT RELATIVELY
HIGH UP IN THE EXHAUST STACKS,
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE. AND OUR 80 YEAR HISTORY,
OUR TRADE ASSOCIATION HAS NEVER
ASKED A LEGISLATURE TO INTERVENE
TO PROTECT LIVES ON BOARD A
VESSEL, BUT THAT IS WHAT IS
NEEDED HERE BECAUSE CARB DID NOT
ACT BEFORE. WE DO NOT EXPECT
THEM TO PRIORITIZE MARINER AND
WORKPLACE SAFETY IN THE FUTURE.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF AB 1122.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ARE THERE OTHERS IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS A SUPPORT
POSITION ON THE BILL? IF SO,
PLEASE COME FORWARD, IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND SUPPORT. HI, MY
NAME IS KEVIN HARLEY. I'M A
MARITIME PROFESSIONAL AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL FOR THE SAFETY
OF THE ENVIRONMENT AND THE
CREWS. THANK YOU. MAX ROSENBERG
WITH FAIN BROTHERS COMPANIES.
AND I SUPPORT MARINER SAFETY IN
THIS BILL. I'M MICHAEL MYERS, A
MARITIME EXECUTIVE AND FORMER
TUGBOAT CAPTAIN AND CREW. WE
SUPPORT AB 1122 FOR THE SAFETY
OF OUR WORKFORCE. MR. CHAIR
MEMBER SARA FLOCKS, CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION, IN SUPPORT.
ANANYA AKKIRAJU ON BEHALF OF THE
JUNIOR PHILANTHROPIST FOUNDATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
JEREMY PRICE, REPRESENTING
SINCLAIR AND SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES HERE TO PRESENT SEEING
NONE. IS THERE? YES. IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS AND
OPPOSE POSITION? THEY'RE NOT IN
OPPOSITION. THEY'RE IN CONCERN.
OKAY, LET ME FINISH WITH THE
OPPOSITION, PLEASE, FOR JUST A
MOMENT. ONE LAST CALL FOR ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS AN OPPOSED
POSITION. YOU MAY COME UP NOW TO
THE MICROPHONE. Ã SEEING NONE.
I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE FOLKS WHO
ARE IN BETWEEN AND WANT TO
EXPRESS THEIR POSITION. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO LIMIT YOU
TO 30S TO JUST IDENTIFY VÌ YOUR
CONCERN. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MY NAME IS THERESA BUI.
I'M WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENT, WE BELIEVE
THAT AB 1122 FOR THE MOST OF IT
IS UNNECESSARY BECAUSE CARB IS
ALREADY GOING THROUGH AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER PROCESS THAT
COVERS THE BULK OF THE BILL. AND
THEN WE HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS WITH
SECTION H WHERE IT COULD BE USED
BY BAD ACTORS TO DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF HARBOR CRAFT.
HARBOR CRAFT IS THE NUMBER, ONE
OF THE TOP THREE EMISSION CAUSED
CANCER CAUSING EMISSIONS AT THE
PORTS. AND SO WE NEED CARB TO BE
ABLE TO FULLY IMPLEMENT THE
RULE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. NEXT GOOD AFTERNOON,
MELISSA ROMERO WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS ECHOING THE
COMMENTS OF TERESA WITH PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENT AND JUST POINTING
OUT IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
SOMETHING THAT WAS RAISED IS
THAT SECTION, SUBSECTION H, THE
LAST SECTION OF THE BILL COULD
DELAY THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
HARBOR CRAFT RULE BY ANYWHERE
BETWEEN TWO AND A HALF TO FIVE
YEARS. SO WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON
MAKING SURE THAT THAT IS NOT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN, BECAUSE
THAT WOULD BE A CAUSE OF CONCERN
FOR US. THANKS. THANK YOU.
HELLO. MICHELLE KANELLIS, UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS JUST
WANT TO ALIGN OUR ORGANIZATION
WITH THE SAME CONCERNS STATED.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. SENATOR DARLING.
WELL, FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THE BILL.
FATHER IS MY FATHER IN LAW'S A
MERCHANT MARINE. AND OBVIOUSLY
SOMEBODY WHO'S WORKING WITH
ONCE, ONCE THEY'RE MOVING. IT'S
NOT LIKE, JUST PUT THE BRAKES
ON. THEY STOP, AS WE SAW
EARLIER. AND ALSO, I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT, SENATOR NILO HAD A
BILL EARLIER THIS YEAR, TRYING
TO ASK FOR SOME EXEMPTIONS FROM
CARBS. AND WE ACTUALLY SAT DOWN
WITH MET WITH CARB, ALONG WITH
THE EC CHAIR, ABOUT TWO WEEKS
AGO, I BELIEVE IT WAS. AND SO WE
REALLY DO NEED TO DO SOME WORK
IN THIS AREA. THEY NEED TO GIVE
SOME EXEMPTIONS FOR SAFETY, NOT
ONLY THAT, SOMEBODY WHO'S IN THE
TRUCKING BUSINESS MYSELF, WHO
WENT THROUGH THE DPF FILTERS AND
THE FIRES AND, YOU KNOW, SCHOOL
BUSSES AND LIKES PEOPLE LOST
THEIR LIVES. SO I WILL MOVE THE
BILL WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE. I
THINK WE NEED TO DO THIS
EXEMPTION. IT'S COMMON SENSE TO
ME. AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT'S
JUST COMMON SENSE AND IT'S
SAFETY, CARB WILL BE A LONG TIME
AND THE MANUFACTURERS TOO ARE
HAVING A HARD TIME MEETING THESE
SPECIFICATIONS. AND THE COST TO
REPLACE THOSE PIECES OF
EQUIPMENT ARE HUGE AS WELL. SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD. ANYONE ELSE ON THE
COMMITTEE? YES, SENATOR NILA.
THIS IS ONE OF MANY EXAMPLES OF,
OF, REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS PUT
FORTH BY CARB THAT, CURRENTLY
CAN'T BE MET OR CAN'T BE MET IN
THIS CASE SAFELY. AND YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE, ROAD APPLICATION AND,
BOAT APPLICATION, AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REALIZE THAT,
PROBLEMS AT SEA ARE MUCH LESS
FORGIVING THAN THOSE ON THE
ROAD. AND WE'RE ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT. SO, I AM SUPPORTING THIS
BILL, BUT ALSO STATING THAT I
THINK WE IN THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
MORE WORK TO DO RELATIVE TO THE
CURRENT, REQUIREMENTS THAT CARB
IS IMPOSING, PARTICULARLY WITH
REGARD TO CASES WHERE THE
TECHNOLOGY JUST DOESN'T EXIST
YET. Ó. THANK YOU, VICE CHAIR.
ANYONE ELSE ON THE COMMITTEE
WISH TO SPEAK ON THE ITEM, WE'LL
GO BACK TO THE AUTHOR FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. AND IF YOU
COULD ADDRESS, THE COMMENTS MADE
BY THE TWEENERS, THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL, I THINK. THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY LIKE I SAID, I
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE INPUT FOR
THIS BILL, IT'S SOMETHING THAT
FOR ME, WORKING THE DISASTER
MANAGEMENT ROLE, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I DO AS PART OF
MY DAILY ROUTINE AS A PHYSICIAN
THAT WORKS TO IMPLEMENT AND
CREATE PROTOCOLS FOR DISASTER
MANAGEMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I'VE BEEN DOING
FOR VERY MANY YEARS. AND THE
SAFETY OF OUR MARITIME PEOPLE
THAT ARE OUT THERE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR ANY OF OUR
WORKERS, FIRST OF ALL, THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER HAS NOT BEEN
DONE YET. I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING SOMETHING AND WHEN IT
COMES OUT, WE WILL DEFINITELY
TAKE A LOOK AT IT. HOWEVER,
THERE IS NO EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT
HAS BEEN SUBMITTED AND THE IF IT
IS SUBMITTED, IT WOULD NOT
ADDRESS THE UNION WAGES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE LOST, WHICH I
DISCUSSED EARLIER, NOT JUST
THAT, I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
ARE CONCERNS WITH THE FILTERS
AND THE REASON AND BEHIND WHAT
CREATED THIS. HOWEVER, WE DO
ALSO HAVE TO TAKE ACCOUNTABILITY
OF THE LIVES THAT CAN BE LOST
TODAY. AS A PHYSICIAN, MY JOB IS
TO SAVE LIVES AND NOT TO
SACRIFICE LIVES TODAY FOR LIVES
THAT MIGHT BE TAKEN 30 YEARS
FROM NOW. IT'S ABOUT THE LIVES
THAT MIGHT BE SACRIFICED TODAY
AND THERE ARE THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION THAT HAVE GOOD
INTENTIONS. HOWEVER THEY ARE NOT
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT WHAT IS
HAPPENING TODAY AND THE IMPACT
IT CAN TAKE ON LIVES TODAY THAT
WE SEE IN DISASTER MANAGEMENT.
SO I APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S INPUT
. I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
EVERYONE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS WHICH HAVE NOT OPPOSED
THIS BILL, TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS ADDRESSES ALL THE CONCERNS.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME PROTECTS
LIVES. TODAY THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. I TRUST
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM. WE
HAVE EARLIER, WE WILL, ASK FOR A
ROLL CALL, VOTE ON THE MOTION BY
SENATOR DOOLEY. THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE, AB 1122. THE
MOTION IS Dð PASS. AND WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. SENATORS
CORTEZ A CORTEZ. AYE NILO. AYE
NILA. AYE. ALAN ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER
SHAKESPEARE. SHAKESPEARE. AYE.
DOLLY DOLLY. AYE. DODD. DODD.
AYE. GONZALEZ LIMON. NEWMAN.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NGUYEN. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE
SATO. UMBERG. 901. CALL. OKAY.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 9 TO 0.
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU, CHAIRMAN CORTEZ
. WE'RE NEXT GOING TO GO TO ITEM
FOUR. IF SOMEBODY THAT'S THE
BOTTOM NUMBER NINE CORNER. BUT
SHE DOESN'T THINK SHE'S HERE.
SHE IS. YES. NUMBER NINE. NUMBER
NINE. ALL RIGHT I APOLOGIZE. WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM NINE,
NO APOLOGY TO THE AUTHOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BORNER. I'M SURE
SHE DOESN'T MIND BEING CALLED UP
AT THIS TIME, YOU MAY PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THIS IS
AB 1850. I'M SORRY. THIS IS AB
2234. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS. FIRST, I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS BILL.
I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY. AB 2234 WOULD
AUTHORIZE A FOUR YEAR OPT IN
PILOT PROJECT IN THE COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO, BANNING CLASS ONE AND
TWO E-BIKES FOR ANYONE UNDER THE
AGE OF 12, CONSISTENT WITH THE
DATA FROM THE CONSUMER PRODUCT
SAFETY COMMISSION, THE COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO AND CITIES WITHIN THE
COUNTY WOULD HAVE TO PASS AN
ORDINANCE OR RESOLUTION TO
IMPLEMENT THE PILOT PROGRAM,
WITH REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
MIRRORING THE RACIAL AND
IDENTITY PROFILING ACT, RIPA
E-BIKES ARE BECOMING AN
INCREASINGLY COMMON AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY MODE OF
TRANSPORTATION FOR BOTH
RECREATION AND COMMUTING.
HOWEVER WITH THE SURGE OF
E-BIKES, INJURIES HAVE OCCURRED
BOTH MORE FREQUENTLY AND WITH
MORE SEVERE INJURIES. IN AUGUST
OF 2022, THE CARLSBAD CITY
COUNCIL APPROVED AN E-BIKE
EMERGENCY PROCLAMATION DUE TO A
233% INCREASE IN ACCIDENTS
INVOLVING E-BIKES AND BICYCLES.
AS A RESPONSE, THE CITY COUNCIL
APPROVED CARLSBAD SPECIFIC RULES
FOR E-BIKE RIDERS, WHICH
PROVIDED CARLSBAD POLICE
OFFICERS WITH MORE ENFORCEMENT
OPTIONS, INCLUDING AN E-BIKE
SAFETY PROGRAM SIMILAR TO A
TRAFFIC SCHOOL FOR BIKES, WHERE
E-BIKE RIDERS HAVE THE OPTION TO
COMPLETE AN E-BIKE SAFETY COURSE
AFTER AN E-BIKE CITATION SHORTLY
THEREAFTER, IN MAY 2023, A
TEENAGER IN THE CITY OF
ENCINITAS LOST HIS LIFE AND AN
E-BIKE COLLISION WITH A
MOTORIZED VEHICLE. SIMILAR
E-BIKE TRAINING PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN ESTABLISHED IN THE CITIES
OF ENCINITAS AND CORONADO, WITH
A CONTINUED POPULARITY OF
E-BIKES. AB 2234 WOULD HELP
REDUCE THE INCIDENCE AND
INCREASE SAFETY FOR ALL E-BIKE
RIDERS AND DRIVERS ALIKE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME I HAVE SHARON
GONSALVES ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF CARLSBAD, THE SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. YOU MAY PROCEED. YOU'LL
HAVE A COUPLE MINUTES. GREAT.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, SHARON GONSALVES
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
CARLSBAD. FIRST, I WANT TO
EXPRESS THE CITY'S SINCERE
GRATITUDE TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR NOT ONLY SPONSORING THIS
BILL, BUT HER CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP ON E-BIKE SAFETY. AB
2234, THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
ELECTRIC BICYCLE SAFETY PILOT
PROGRAM IS A CRUCIAL INITIATIVE
ENABLING CITIES WITHIN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY TO REGULATE E-BIKE USE
AMONG CHILDREN UNDER 12 BY
ALLOWING US TO ENACT LOCAL
ORDINANCES AS MENTIONED IN
CARLSBAD, WE WITNESSED A
STAGGERING 233% INCREASE IN BIKE
AND E-BIKE RELATED ACCIDENTS
BETWEEN 2019 AND 2022, INCLUDING
A COUPLE OF TRAGIC FATALITIES,
WHICH ULTIMATELY LED TO THE
LOCAL STATE OF EMERGENCY. THIS
ALARMING TREND HIGHLIGHTS THE
URGENT NEED FOR MORE STRUCTURED
SAFETY PROTOCOLS. FOLLOWING THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY. CARLSBAD
ROLLED OUT A CITY Ã SCHOOL
E-BIKE PERMIT PROGRAM, WHICH
MANDATED THAT YOUNG RIDERS
COMPLETE A SAFETY COURSE, AND
THIS INITIATIVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
STRIDES IN ENHANCING E-BIKE
SAFETY AMONGST STUDENTS. THE
INTRODUCTION OF AB 2234 IS NOT
JUST ABOUT REGULATION, IT'S
ABOUT ENSURING CHILDREN RECEIVE
PROPER TRAINING AND AWARENESS
ABOUT SAFE OPERATIONS OF
E-BIKES, FURTHER SAFEGUARDING
THE COMMUNITY. E-BIKES CAN REACH
SPEEDS UP TO 28 MILES AN HOUR,
WHICH IS SIMILAR TO MANY, SPEEDS
OF CARS ON CITY STREETS. GIVEN
THESE HIGH SPEEDS, IMPROPER USE
OF E-BIKES CAN BE EXTREMELY
DANGEROUS. AB 2234 EMBODIES THE
STATE'S ONGOING COMMITMENT TO
SAFETY AND REPRESENTS A
STRATEGIC STEP TOWARDS SAFER
E-BIKE USAGE ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
BY SUPPORTING THIS BILL, WE ARE
NOT ONLY ADDRESSING IMMEDIATE
CONCERNS, BUT LAYING THE
GROUNDWORK FOR FUTURE SAFETY
ENHANCEMENTS FOR A GROWING NEW
TRANSPORTATION MEDIUM. AND WITH
THAT, I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU AND
THE COMMITTEE, AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THE CITY'S
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. I
SEE OTHERS COMING FORWARD WHO
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS A SUPPORT
POSITION, NAME AND SUPPORT,
PLEASE. KIM. STONE OF STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION. ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AARON
GILBERT FOR THE CITY OF
ENCINITAS IN SUPPORT C¯ ROSS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF CORONADO
IN SUPPORT. TANYUSHKA
KONDAKARLA. ON BEHALF OF THE
JUNIOR PHILANTHROPIST FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. THAT
CONCLUDES THE SUPPORT SIDE. IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION PRESENT
WISHING TO TESTIFY? IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO JUST SIMPLY
EXPRESS AN OPPOSITION POSITION?
IF SO, YOU MAY COME TO THE
MICROPHONE. I'M SEEING NONE. WE
WILL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
COMMITTEE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SENATOR ARCHULETA? YES. THANK
YOU. AND I KNOW YOU'RE ALWAYS
CONCERNED ABOUT SAFETY, AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. I'M JUST
WONDERING, JUST WALK ME THROUGH.
AN 11 YEAR OLD BOY IS PULLED
OVER BECAUSE HE'S IN AND OUT OF
TRAFFIC AS AN EXAMPLE. BECAUSE I
WOULD IMAGINE IT'S THE ONLY WAY
YOU WOULD BRING ATTENTION TO
HIMSELF IF HE'S OTHER THAN GOING
DOWN THE SIDEWALK. SO HE'S
PULLED OVER IN THE OFFSHORE,
SEES BAGS ON HIM OR SOME
PACKAGES OR WHATEVER. WALK ME
THROUGH THE AUTHORIZATION TO ASK
WHAT'S IN IT, WHERE HE'S COMING
FROM, AND I KNOW HE'S NOT TO ASK
WHERE HE WAS BORN AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE, BUT WHAT WHAT AT
WHAT POINT CAN THE OFFICER ASK
QUESTIONS TO THAT 11 YEAR OLD
WHERE IT'S NOT INCRIMINATING THE
CHILD AND THEN WHAT ARE THE
VIOLATIONS, THAT HE IS WRITING
ON THE SIDEWALK AND SO ON. SO
HOW DO WE GET HIM OFF THE
STREET? IS MY QUESTION. WELL,
THE 11 YEAR OLD, HOPEFULLY EVERY
PARENT WOULD BE VERY THOUGHTFUL.
ONE OF THE REASONS WE'RE DOING
THIS AS A PILOT IS TO COLLECT
THAT DATA. THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS, SEARCH
REQUIREMENTS. NONE OF THIS BILL
DOESN'T AFFECT ANY OF THAT. IT
IS THE SAME THING FOR ANY ANY
BIKE VIOLATION, ANY TRAFFIC
VIOLATION. IT IS CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT WE CURRENTLY DO WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SO THIS BILL
DOESN'T CHANGE ANYTHING ABOUT
HOW THAT WOULD BE LOOKED AT. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WAS AMENDED
OUT OF THE BILL AND THE ASSEMBLY
WAS THE REQUIREMENT FOR AN ID IF
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A VALID
DRIVER'S LICENSE THAT WAS
AMENDED OUT. SO USUALLY WHAT
HAPPENS IN OUR PILOTS IN
ENCINITAS AND CARLSBAD AND
CORONADO IS THEY'LL GO THROUGH,
THEY'LL TRY TO CALL THE PARENTS,
THEY'LL TRY TO CALL, THEY'LL TRY
TO SOMETIMES THEY CONTACT THE
SCHOOLS IF THE SCHOOLS ARE OPEN,
IF IT'S DURING SCHOOL HOURS, TO
CONFIRM THE PERSON'S IDENTITY
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT YOU NEED IN
ORDER TO, TO GIVE A CITATION.
AND THAT'S WHY I IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF THIS BILL IS FOR
THAT CITATION. AND THIS BILL
ONLY GOVERNS THE RIDING AN
E-BIKE UNDER 12 PORTION OF CLASS
ONE AND TWO. AS YOU KNOW, CLASS
THREES ARE ALREADY BANNED FOR
UNDER 16. SO IT WOULD BE THE
SAME PROCESS AS THAT, BUT WHAT
IT WOULD REQUIRE IS IF THERE WAS
A CITATION, THEN THE CITY WHO
OPTS INTO THIS PROGRAM AND THIS
PILOT WOULD HAVE TO DO A E-BIKE
DIVERSION. WE CALL IT DIVERSION
PROGRAMS, BUT IT'S BASICALLY
TRAFFIC SCHOOL FOR E-BIKES. AND
SO THEY WOULD GO THROUGH THAT
AND THEREFORE THEY WOULDN'T GET
THE FINE. AND WOULD IT BE WOULD
THE OFFICER BE ABLE TO
CONFISCATE THE BIKE THAT IS
CURRENT? THAT'S CURRENTLY THE
CASE RIGHT NOW. OKAY. AND
OBVIOUSLY GET IT TO THE STATION,
CALL THE PARENTS. AND AND GET
BACK TO SAFETY AS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. AND WITH THAT, YEAH, THE
DATA IS VERY CLEAR THAT THE MOST
AMOUNT OF INJURIES AND ACCIDENTS
ARE IN THE UNDER 12 SPACE. THAT
AND IF I'M GOING TO USE MY
LOVELY SON WHO HAPPENS TO BE UP
WITH ME THIS WEEK. SO THIS IS
MATEO. HE'S 16, HE WAS BORN 86
YEAR OLD MAN. SO CAN LOOK BOTH
WAYS AND CROSS THE STREET WHEN
HE WAS TWO YEARS OLD. HE'S ONE
OF THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT USES
HAND SIGNALS WHEN HE'S BIKING
THROUGH ENCINITAS. AND PEOPLE
TAKE PICTURES OF HIM AND SEND
THEM TO ME, THEY'RE LIKE, CAN
YOU TEACH ALL THE KIDS AT SAN
DIEGUITO ACADEMY HOW TO RIDE
E-BIKES LIKE THIS? I WAS LIKE,
THAT'S HOW KIDS GET BULLIED. NO,
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE PROGRAMS LIKE
WHAT THE SPONSOR WAS TALKING
ABOUT FOR DOING THE BIKE PARKING
ON CAMPUS. BUT I DIDN'T LET HIM
ON AN E-BIKE UNTIL HE WAS 12.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A WHEREWITHAL TO KNOW HOW
TO NAVIGATE MAIN ARTERIALS,
BECAUSE WITH E-BIKES, THE WORLD
BECOMES FLAT. AND SO YOU CAN
REACH CLASS ONE AND TWOS CAN GO
UP TO 20 MILES AN HOUR. AND IF
YOU'RE GOING DOWNHILL, YOU CAN
GO UP TO 35 MILES AN HOUR. AND
THAT'S JUST WHAT THEY ARE. AND
SO IT'S REALLY THAT'S WHY YOU
HAVE THE BAN FOR UNDER OR UNDER
12 FOR CLASS ONE AND TWO. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE AN OFFER FOR A MOTION.
WE'LL COME BACK TO YOU. SENATOR
ARCHULETA IN A MOMENT. SENATOR
BLAKESBURG. YES. THANK YOU. I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD, IT
WHEN YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH
E-BIKES, YOU REALIZE HOW FAST,
AN E-BIKE CAN GO WITH SUCH
LITTLE EFFORT WHEN IT'S A
THROTTLE BICYCLE. SO IT'S
ESSENTIALLY LIKE A MOTORCYCLE.
YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE TO PEDAL AND
THE KIDS PREFER THOSE, AND
THEY'RE MUCH COOLER. SO THE ONES
THAT ARE SO POPULAR IN THESE
AREAS THAT HAVE GREAT BICYCLE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE KIDS ARE
RUNNING AROUND ON THEIR BIKES,
WHICH IS A REALLY GOOD THING IN
MANY WAYS, BECAUSE IT REALLY
ALLOWS FOR, KIDS TO HAVE MORE
INDEPENDENCE TO TAKE TRIPS OFF
THE ROAD, FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
GET TO SCHOOL OR TO THEIR
PRACTICES OR OTHER THINGS, NOT
HAVING TO GET IN THE CAR AND
HAVE A PARENT OR SOMEBODY ELSE
DRIVE THEM. SO I THINK
INCENTIVIZING BICYCLE USE OF ALL
TYPES IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
VALUE. AND THIS BILL SETS THE
AGE AT THE RIGHT LEVEL, BECAUSE
IF YOU IMAGINE A NINE, TEN, 11
YEAR OLDS, THEY DON'T NEED TO
HAVE THROTTLE BICYCLES TO GET
WHERE THEY NEED TO GO. SO I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU HAVE THIS,
THAT YOU'VE SET IT AT THAT
LEVEL. I ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS BILL REALLY IS FOCUSED
ON LOCAL CONTROL, BECAUSE I ALSO
REPRESENT SAN DIEGO COUNTY AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERNER DOES.
THERE ARE 18 CITIES IN THAT
COUNTY, SO EACH ONE IS ABLE TO
DECIDE IF THEY WANT TO HAVE THIS
OR NOT IN THEIR CITY AND THEN
HAVE THESE DIVERSION PROGRAMS
WHERE THEY'RE ABLE TO GET AN
EDUCATION COURSE IF THEY DO GET
STOPPED BY AN OFFICER. I THINK
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT PART.
THE QUESTION I WANTED TO ASK IS
THAT THE CHILD COULD ATTEND A
CHP DEVELOPED E-BIKE SAFETY
COURSE, AND MY EXPERIENCE WITH
THIS BIKE SAFETY COURSE IS, IS
THAT THEY'RE PUT TOGETHER BY THE
BICYCLE GROUPS, NOT BY THE CHP.
SO I JUST WANTED TO ASK ABOUT
THAT PART. IF THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE POTENTIALLY A
BARRIER. IF THERE'S ONLY A
LIMITED NUMBER OF CHP OFFERED
COURSES OR, OR WHAT YOU KNOW
ABOUT THAT, THERE IS AN ONLINE
CLASS, I THINK YOU WERE NOT YET
HERE, BUT WE PASSED IT TWO YEARS
AGO. IT'S AB 1946 THAT I
AUTHORED THAT CREATED THE
STATEWIDE E-BIKE SAFETY TRAINING
PROGRAM. AND SO MANY OF IT WAS
MADE BY THE CHP IN COLLABORATION
WITH ALL OUR BIKE GROUPS. SO
EVERYBODY IS USING THE 1946 CHP
E-BIKE TRAINING, AND THAT IS THE
STANDARD NOW IN THE STATE. OKAY,
OKAY. SO THE IT'S ONLINE AND
IT'S ONLINE OKAY I SEE OKAY.
GREAT. WELL THANKS VERY MUCH.
AND I'M EXCITED TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NO ONE ELSE WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED, WE'LL REITERATE THAT
SENATOR ARCHULETA HAS MADE A
MOTION. WE'LL ASK THE ASSISTANT
TO TAKE A ROLL CALL. VOTE IN A
MINUTE, BUT WE'LL GIVE THE
AUTHOR ONE MORE OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE HERE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE. VOTE THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB 2234. THE MOTION
IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED. AND
REREFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS CORTEZ,
CORTEZ. AYE. NILO. NILO. AYE.
ALLEN. ARCHULETA ARCHULETA. AYE.
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. DALLI. DALLI. AYE.
DODD. DODD AYE. GONZALEZ. LIMON.
NEWMAN NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN.
NGUYEN. AYE. PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO. AYE. SATO SATO. AYE.
UMBERG. TEN ZERO ONE KHÔNG.
OKAY. THAT VOTE IS 10 TO 0, BUT
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
TÍNH IS HERE. SO ALL RIGHT,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
15, I BELIEVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING IS HERE AND YOU MAY COME
FORWARD TO PRESENT. THAT IS AB
2869 AND YOU MAY BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AB 2669 PROTECTS FREE
SIDEWALK ACCESS FOR PEDESTRIANS
AND BIKERS ON OUR, ON OUR
BRIDGES CONSTRUCTED BEFORE
JANUARY 2025. SO ANY BRIDGE
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN CONSTRUCTED
AND HAVING PEDESTRIAN AND
BICYCLIST, ACCESS WOULD REMAIN
FREE FOR THOSE, PEDESTRIANS AND
CYCLISTS, THIS BILL MERELY
EXTENDS OR MAKES PERMANENT A
BILL THAT I DID A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO, THAT TEMPORARILY HAD
THAT MORATORIUM. SO WE'RE JUST
MAKING THAT PERMANENT. WITH
THAT, WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE,
JEANNIE WALLER, WHO'S A LOBBYIST
FOR CAL BIKE. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. YOU'LL HAVE A COUPLE
MINUTES. OKAY, I WILL BE QUICK,
JEANNIE WALLER WITH FEARLESS
ADVOCACY REPRESENTING CAL BIKE
ON THIS BILL, CAL BIKE IS A
CO-SPONSOR OF THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
THAT WILL PROMOTE NON-VEHICULAR
FORMS OF TRANSPORTATION ACROSS
ALL BRIDGES THAT HELP TO IMPROVE
AIR QUALITY, COMBAT CLIMATE
CHANGE, AND ENSURE EQUITABLE
ACCESS. CHOOSING NOT TO IMPOSE A
TOLL HAVE HAS KEPT STATE BRIDGES
OPEN AND ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
INDIVIDUALS, WHILE EXEMPLIFYING
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
CUTTING CARBON EMISSIONS AND
FOSTERING SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION ALTERNATIVES.
FREE PUBLIC ACCESS TO BRIDGES
ACROSS THE STATE HAS ALSO
BOLSTERED DECADES OF WORK TO
PROMOTE PUBLIC RECREATION BY
LINKING TOGETHER A NETWORK OF
PARKS, PATHS AND TRAILS. WE MUST
DO ALL WE CAN TO REPLACE CAR
TRIPS WITH ACTIVE FORMS OF
MOBILITY AND INCREASING VMT AND
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHPUT.
IMPROVEMENTS EXCLUSIVELY FOR
CARS CONTINUE TO IMPEDE OUR
EFFORTS TO CURB VEHICLE
EMISSIONS. WE REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB 2669. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES
TO COME FORWARD AND EXPRESS THE
SUPPORT POSITION? SEEING NO ONE
SEEING. YES, WE DO HAVE SOMEONE
COMING FORWARD AND, TANISHKA
KANAKALA ON BEHALF OF THE JUNIOR
PHILANTHROPIST FOUNDATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
COMING FORWARD NOW? LAST CALL,
MARK VUKOVICH, ON BEHALF OF
STREETS FOR ALL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? WE'LL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION? WE
DON'T HAVE A REGISTERED
OPPOSITION WITNESS. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
COME FORWARD AND SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE, WE'LL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AT
THIS TIME. SENATOR DODD, MOVE
THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE.
SENATOR DODD'S OFFERED A MOTION.
SENATOR BREAKSPEARE, YES. THIS
IS A GREAT BILL THAT REALLY
SHOWS A REFLECTION OF WHAT WE
WANT TO INCENTIVIZE AND WHICH IS
MORE BIKING AND WALKING. SO I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU THOUGHT TO
ELIMINATE THE IT COMPLETELY THE,
THE FEE, OR THE POSSIBILITY OF
ONE IN THE FUTURE. SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY I THINK THAT'S GREAT
THINKING AND I AM EAGER TO VOTE.
YES. THANK YOU. OKAY, WE DO HAVE
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY SENATOR
DODD WILL GIVE THE AUTHOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE, AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE TO A ROLL CALL VOTE.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND JUST
JUST SUPER BRIEFLY, THE BILL'S
ORIGIN CAME THROUGH BECAUSE OUR
GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE, THE MOST
FAMOUS BRIDGE IN CALIFORNIA,
ACTUALLY WAS CONSIDERING
CHARGING A TOLL FOR PEDESTRIANS
AND FOR BICYCLISTS DURING THEIR
BUDGET SHORTFALL. SO, AGAIN, WE
DON'T REALLY WANT ANY BRIDGE
AUTHORITY TO BE TEMPTED LIKE
THAT. REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
VOTE AND SUPPORT ON 2669. THANK
YOU. AND ASSISTANT, WE'LL GO
WITH THE ROLL CALL VOTE AT THIS
TIME PLEASE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER 15 AB 2669. THE MOTION IS
Dð PASS. AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE.
NILO ALLEN ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA.
AYE. BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. DALLY. DODD. AYE
DODD. AYE. GONZALEZ. LIMON.
NEWMAN NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN.
PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO AYE.
SATO. UMBERG. 6015. ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S A60 VOTE, BUT IT'S ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK
YOU AGAIN. ALL RIGHT. 1871, AN
ITEM 18. ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOHN
SAWYER. THAT IS YOUR ITEM. IT IS
AB 3123. WELCOME. AND PLEASE
COME FORWARD AND YOU CAN BEGIN
YOUR PRESENTATION WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND SPEAKERS, I PRESENT
AB 3123, WHICH SEEKS TO ENSURE
THAT ETHICS LAWS THAT GOVERN
ELECTED OFFICIALS STATEWIDE
APPLY EQUALLY TO THE LOS ANGELES
METRO BOARD OF DIRECTORS, WITH
THE RECENT PASSAGE OF SB 1439,
WHICH AMENDED THE LEVINE ACT IN
2023, CALIFORNIA MADE CLEAR THAT
THERE SHOULD BE A UNIFORM ETHICS
LAW GOVERNING CONTRACT DECISIONS
BY LOCAL AND STATE OFFICIALS,
REGARDLESS OF THE COMPOSITION OF
A BOARD OR COMMISSION. HOWEVER,
L.A. METRO IS STILL SUBJECT TO A
30 YEAR OLD LAW THAT IMPOSES
DIFFERENT STANDARDS ON BOARD
MEMBERS REGARDING CONTRACT
DECISIONS AND CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM CONTRACTORS.
FOR EXAMPLE, UNDER THE LAW,
BOARD MEMBERS ARE PROHIBITED
FROM ACCEPTING CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS OVER $10, WHILE
THE LEVINE ACT PROHIBITS
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS OVER
$250. THESE DIFFERING STANDARDS
AND REQUIREMENTS HAVE MADE IT
DIFFICULT FOR LA METRO TO COMPLY
WITH, SIMPLY BECAUSE BOARD
MEMBERS ARE SUBJECT TO BOTH THE
LEVINE ACT AND THE HAYDEN BILL
IN THEIR ROLES AS METRO BOARD
MEMBERS, LA METRO SEEKS TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH ALL OTHER
OFFICIALS IN THE STATE MAKING
CONTRACT DECISIONS UNDER MADE
UNDER CERTAIN UNDER THE
STANDARDS AND GUIDANCE OF THE
LEVINE ACT, WHICH GOVERNS THEIR
PRIMARY ELECTED POSITIONS. AB
3123 IS A NARROWLY TAILORED BILL
THAT WILL BRING THE METRO BOARD
INTO ALIGNMENT WITH THE LEVINE
ACT BY REMOVING OUT-OF-DATE
LANGUAGE ON GIFTS, HONORARIA,
TRAVEL, AND FINANCIAL CONFLICTS
THAT CONTRAST WITH CURRENT
APPLICABLE STATE LAW AND METRO
CODE OF CONDUCT. THIS BILL ALSO
MAKES CHANGES TO METRO'S
LOBBYIST REGISTRATION STATUTE,
ALIGNING REPORTING REQUIREMENTS,
STANDARDS, AND PROHIBITIONS WITH
SIMILAR AGENCIES. FINALLY, AB
3123 CODIFIES THE SPECIFIC
AUTHORITY OF METRO'S ETHICS
DEPARTMENT AND MANDATES ITS
INDEPENDENCE. WITH ME IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL ARE ALEX AMADEO, OF
LA METRO, AND PAUL SALAS, CHIEF
ETHICS OFFICER FOR LA METRO. ALL
RIGHT, PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PROCEED. YOU'LL HAVE A COUPLE
MINUTES EACH. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS ALEX AMADEO, AND I AM
THE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
ADMINISTRATOR HERE ON BEHALF OF
LA METRO. METRO IS THE PROUD
SPONSOR OF AB 3123. WE'D LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOAN
SAWYER. I WOULD LIKE TO NOW TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE PAUL
SOLIS, WHO IS L.A. METRO'S CHIEF
ETHICS OFFICER, TO TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THIS BILL,
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS PAUL SOLIS, METRO'S
CHIEF ETHICS OFFICER. METRO IS A
THIRD LARGEST TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM IN THE UNITED STATES AND
HAS ONE OF THE LARGEST CAPITAL
CONSTRUCTION AND SYSTEM
EXPANSION PROGRAMS IN THE
NATION. TO PREPARE FOR THE 2028
OLYMPICS AND BEYOND. I'M A BOARD
APPOINTED OFFICER AND MEMBER OF
THE STATE BAR OF CALIFORNIA,
CURRENTLY I ADVISE THE LA METRO
BOARD ON ISSUES RELATED TO STATE
PAY TO PLAY LAWS. METRO SUBJECT
TO TWO OF THESE LAWS, ONE IN THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE THAT
APPLIES EXCLUSIVELY TO METRO,
AND ONE OF THE GOVERNMENT CODE
KNOWN AS THE LEVINE ACT THAT
APPLIES STATEWIDE. THE METRO
SPECIFIC PUC LAW EMPLOYS
DIFFERENT TERMS LANGUAGE, DOLLAR
AMOUNTS AND TIME PERIODS THAN
THE LEVINE ACT. IMPORTANTLY,
LEVINE ACT HAS AMPLE
INTERPRETIVE GUIDANCE ISSUED BY
THE FPPC AND COURTS, WHILE THE
PUC LAW HAS VIRTUALLY NONE. THIS
CREATES ISSUES WITH COMPLIANCE,
AND IT'S FRANKLY VERY CONFUSING.
IT ALSO CREATES LIABILITY AND
RISK FOR METRO. THE CURRENT
SPONSORED AMENDMENTS WOULD ALLOW
THE LEVINE ACT TO GOVERN METRO'S
PAY TO PLAY RESPONSIBILITY IS
CONSISTENT WITH ALL OTHER LOCAL
AGENCIES IN THE STATE, AND THE
INTENT OF THIS LEGISLATURE, AS
EXPRESSED IN 2023, THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS. I WANT TO
BRIEFLY EXPLAIN. FIRST, THE BILL
WOULD MAKE AMENDMENTS TO METRO'S
LOBBYIST REGISTRATION STATUTE,
KEEPING IT CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
JURISDICTIONS LIKE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. NEXT, THE BILL WOULD
REMOVE OUT-OF-DATE LANGUAGE IN
THE BOARD'S CODE OF CONDUCT THAT
CONTRASTS WITH CURRENT
APPLICABLE STATE LAW AND METRO'S
ADMINISTRATIVE CODES. THE BILL
WOULD ALSO ENACT CHANGES AND
ADDITIONS THAT EXIST IN PEER
AGENCY CODES. FINALLY, THIS BILL
STRENGTHENS METRO'S ETHICS
DEPARTMENT BY SPECIFYING ITS
AUTHORITY AND RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE BOARD AND AGENCY. IT ALSO
ADDS A TWO THIRDS VOTE
REQUIREMENT INSTEAD OF A SIMPLE
MAJORITY FOR THE BOARD TO FIRE
THE ETHICS OFFICER THE SAME AS
METRO'S INSPECTOR GENERAL. IN
CONCLUSION, METRO'S SIMPLY
SEEKING TO IMPLEMENT A CLEAR
SYSTEM WHERE BOARD MEMBERS,
EMPLOYEES, LOBBYISTS, AND
CONTRACTORS CAN ALL HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT THEY'RE
KNOWLEDGEABLE AND COMPLIANT WITH
IMPORTANT ETHICS LAWS AND RULES.
THUS, METRO SUPPORTS AB 3123.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. ARE THERE
OTHERS IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO
WISH TO STEP FORWARD AND EXPRESS
THE SUPPORT POSITION? IF SO,
PLEASE DO SO NOW. GOOD
AFTERNOON. ON ON YOUR
KARAGEORGIOU ON BEHALF OF THE
JUNIOR PHILANTHROPIST FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE, I WAS FOOLED
BY A DECOY THERE. OKAY SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OPPOSITION.
THERE'S NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION
WITNESS. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION? I'VE SEEN NO ONE
COME FORWARD. WE'LL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE. THE BILL
IS MOVED BY SENATOR NEWMAN.
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE AUTHOR
FOR AN OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. AND WE'LL COME BACK
TO THE ASSISTANT FOR ANOTHER
ROLL CALL. VOTE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER 18, AB 3123. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS
AND CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS.
SENATOR CORTESE Ã ORTEZ I NILO
ALLEN ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER, BLAKE.
SPEER, I DALLY, I DALLY I DODD.
DODD I GONZALEZ. LIMÓN NEWMAN.
NEWMAN, I NGUYEN. WHEN NØ
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I SATO.
SATO. NÓ UMBERG. 721 CALL. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE AT A 7 TO 2 VOTE
RIGHT NOW. SEVEN EYES, AND I'LL
LEAVE THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH. WE APPRECIATE IT. WE'RE
WAITING FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
OKAY. WE ARE. WHILE WE'RE
WAITING TO SEE IF OUR LAST
AUTHOR MAKES IT DOWN HERE IN
TIME, WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND LIFT THE CALL. WE'LL START
WITH CONSENT CALENDAR. THIS IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS.
CORTESE. Ã ORTEZ. AYE. GONZALEZ
LIMÓN SATO. SATO. AYE. UMBERG 12
ZERO ON. YOU KNOW. NO. YOU YOU
MOVED IT. YEAH. COME ON. HEY
RELAX. 12 ZERO. YOU'RE BUYING
THE BEER ANYWAY. OKAY, WE'LL
LEAVE THAT ON CALL. BUT IT IS UP
TO 12 ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO OTHER BILLS ON
CALL. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB 2290. SENATORS CORTESE A
CORTESE AYE. GONZALEZ LIMÓN
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE. SATO SATO
NØ. UMBERG. 8824 ON CALL. ALL
RIGHT. AB. 229090 IS UP TO 8 TO
0 AT 8 TO 4. I'M SORRY, 8 TO 4.
I APOLOGIZE TO THE DISSENT AND
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL. THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
1122. CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATORS ALAN BECKER
, GONZALEZ NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE.
SATO. SERRATO. AYE. UMBERG 11
ZERO ON CALL. ALL RIGHT, 11 ZERO
ON CALL. FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR,
AB 1853. CHAIR. VICE CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. SENATORS. CORTESE
AYE. CORTESE AYE. GONZALEZ LIMÓN
SATO. SATO, AYE. UMBERG 312
ZERO. ON CALL 12 TO 0 ON CALL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
2234. CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATORS ALAN BECKER
. HI. BECKER I GONZALEZ. LIMON
UMBERG 11 ZERO ON CALL. 11 ZERO
ON CALL. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER 15, AB 2669. CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATORS NILO ALAN BECKER.
BECKER I DALI. GONZALEZ LIMÓN
NGUYEN. SATO NGUYEN NÓ DE LO NØ.
NILO NØ. WHEN NÓ SATO UMBERG. 7
TO 2 ON CALL. ALL RIGHT. ITEM 15
IS CURRENTLY 7 TO 2, AND WE'LL
STAY ON CALL. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER 18, AB 3123. CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATORS NILO ALLEN BECKER.
HI. BECKER I GONZALEZ. LIMON
UMBERG. 8 TO 2 ON CALL. NIELSEN.
NÓ NILO NØ. 9 TO 2. SORRY. 8 TO
3 ON FILE. ITEM 18 IS 8 TO 3.
CURRENTLY LIVING ON CALL. THAT'S
IT. FOR THAT. SO WILSON. ALL
RIGHT. WE ARE GOING TO PUT FILE
ITEM 19 AB 3138 OVER TO THE NEXT
HEARING. THAT WAS AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON AGAIN
FOLLOWED HIM 19 AB 3138 IS PUT
OVER TO THE NEXT HEARING. THAT
LEAVES US WITH NO, NO FURTHER
HEARINGS, NO FURTHER BILL
HEARINGS TODAY, WE DO HAVE SOME
ABSENT MEMBERS. I'M SURE WE'RE
TRYING TO GET THEM HERE NOW. ARE
WE DONE? ARE WE DONE? WERE YOU
HERE FOR THE CALL? NO, NO, I
WASN'T.
WITH THE ASSETS. SORRY, MR.
CHAIR, JUST FINISHED.
TRAINS ON THIS COMMITTEE. THAT'S
A RECORD I KNOW. DON'T TELL THE.
SORRY. VICE CHAIR NHIÀU. YOU'VE
CONCLUDED YOUR VOTING. AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR EARLIER
SERVICE PRESIDING OVER THE
MEETING. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. I ALMOST FELT
IMPORTANT. YOU ARE IMPORTANT.
WE'RE GOING TO CREATE MORE OF
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES. SO.
CAN YOU TELL ME WHO VOTED?
FOLKS, WE'RE GOING TO WAIT A
MINUTE OR TWO TO SEE IF WE CAN
GET OUR FINAL TWO ABSENT MEMBERS
HERE. THEY'RE EVIDENTLY ON THEIR
WAY. IF WITHIN. LET'S RUN
THROUGH THEM A COUPLE MINUTES.
OKAY SO TWO MINUTES AND WE'LL
WE'LL RUN THROUGH THEM IF
THEY'RE NOT HERE. THANK YOU.
I'M GOING TO ASK THE ASSISTANT
TO GO AHEAD AND LIFT THE CALL
ONE MORE TIME AND RUN THROUGH
THE BILLS, SENATORS, ALLEN AND
UMBERG AND ANYONE ELSE HERE WHO
NEEDS TO VOTE. WE'RE GOING TO
LIFT THE CALL. VOTE ON THAT YET?
OKAY OKAY. I NEED TO GET THE
CENTER OF ATTENTION. HE'S GOING
TO CALL. YEAH, HE'LL HEAR HIS
NAME. OKAY, THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING. AYE. SENATORS GONZALEZ
LIMÓN UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
TÍNH ZERO ON FALL, 13 ZERO ON
CALL. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO, AB 20 290. CHAIR VOTING
AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
SENATORS GONZALEZ LIMÓN UMBERG
UMBERG. AYE. 9 TO 4 ON CALL. 9
TO 4 ON CALL. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB 1122. CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
ALLEN. AYE. ALLEN. AYE. BECKER.
BECKER. AYE GONZALEZ. LIMÓN.
UMBERG UMBERG. AYE. 13 TO 0 ON
CALL. 13 TO 0 ON CALL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB 1853. CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR. VOTING AYE. SENATORS
GONZALEZ LIMÓN UMBERG UMBERG.
AYE 13 ZERO ONE. CALL 13 ZERO ON
CALL FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
2234. CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATORS ALLEN ALLEN
AYE. GONZALEZ LIMÓN UMBERG
UMBERG. AYE 13 ZERO 113 ZERO
ONE. CALL THIS FILE ITEM NUMBER
15 AB 2669. CHAIR VOTING AYE.
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATORS
ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE DALI.
GONZALEZ. LIMON SATO. UMBERG.
UMBERG AYE. 9 TO 2 ON CALL. 9 TO
2 ON CALL FILE. ITEM NUMBER 18
AB 3123. CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATORS ALLEN.
ALLEN. AYE. GONZALEZ. LIMON
LIMON. AYE. UMBERG. UMBERG. AYE.
CALL GONZALEZ 11 TO 3. 1111 TO 3
ON CALL. WE MIGHT AS WELL START
OFF. WE'RE ABOUT TO START. OKAY
DID YOU DID YOU FINISH GOING
THROUGH THEM? BECAUSE, SENATOR.
THANK YOU GUYS. OKAY. THIS IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE. LIMÓN
LIMÓN. AYE. 15 ZERO OUT, 15
ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO, AB 2290. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTING
NO. SENATORS GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ
AYE. LIMÓN. LIMÓN. AYE. 11 TO 4.
11 TO 4. THE BILL IS OUT. OKAY
SORRY. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE. AB 1122. CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
GONZALEZ LIMÓN. AYE. LIMÓN. AYE
14 ZERO OUT 14 ZERO. THE BILL IS
OUT. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR, AB 1853. CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE LIMÓN
LIMÓN. AYE. 15 ZERO 15 ZERO. THE
BILL IS OUT. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE, AB 2234. CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE. LIMÓN
LIMÓN. AYE 15 ZERO 15 ZERO. THE
BILL IS OUT. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER 15, AB 2669. CHAIR VOTING
AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
SENATORS DALLI. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. LIMÓN LIMÓN. AYE.
SEYARTO THREE. 11 TO 2 OUT. 11
TO 2. THE BILL IS OUT. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER 18, AB 3123.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SENATORS GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. 12 TO 3 OUT. 12
TO 3. THE BILL IS OUT. AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA FOR TODAY.
THANK YOU AGAIN EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED AND EVERYONE STILL
REMAINING THE MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.